you are so cool oh my God I was just
looking at you backstage your jeans do
you look amazing you're a total rock
star you came out here with this is why
they call you the wom who dresses
America only the cool on though yeah
yeah I was like the cool Americans
Welcome to New York by the way thank you
thank you so love it I love it here yes
good okay then you st so you're now a
fan favorite of the show how does that
feel I mean I think I'm a favorite of
some everyone was very excited we were
coming there are people on the crew that
were like she's coming I was like oh my
gosh yeah I think what's nice about this
season is that everyone has somebody
different to kind of plug into we're all
pretty different like you know much more
divers I think between age and ethnicity
and background and age I'm the old one
yeah yeah no one thinks about that yeah
I was like no one thinks old when they
look at you they just think damn I'm not
that cool yeah no that's not what
they're thinking they are thinking that
wait did Andy con have to actually
convince you to do it I mean convince is
a strong word we had to come to Jesus so
we knew each other prior um and at the
very end we were sort of getting ready
to sort of do the final decision that he
and I spoke on the phone and he said
exactly that he didn't want to convince
me he was like you have to make the
decision on your own because it's a
really vulnerable situation and anything
that you don't want people to know they
will know these fans are they're like
forensic scientists if any of you are
out there I know you I know you know
everything yeah so do you have like a
tagline I feel like everybody has a
tagline and let's talk about that ring
later okay okay well I more of them
because okay so I have a line of
eyelashes cuz I don't have any eyelashes
myself um my lashes may be affordable
but everything else is priceless oh I
like that I thought that one was good I
like that I like we did my shoes are
almost as high as my expectations oh hey
but you know what though that's great
why would you lower your bar exactly
exactly why would I I think if you
expect Excellence for yourself there's
no problem in expecting that from others
see I accept average for myself so I
accept average I honestly prefer average
I'm much more comfortable I was so happy
when standing back back there I was so
nervous and then I heard you fumble and
I'm like see she oh my gosh just stick
around you're going to feel great about
yourself yeah we're not I my goal is to
be live with this show and my whole team
is like
sure it'd be a very different show if
you like to tune into a train wreck um
but yeah I'm just train wre I know hey
and it's popular so there you go so you
have a 17-year-old son so but but you're
so cool so I picture your son being like
Mom is this cool like what I'm wearing
does he ask you for advice you seem like
the cool Mom I'm you can ask him that I
mean I am kind of surprised cuz my son
who wants to be an engineer is like I
actually ask him for advice cuz he has
an eye like there'll be times when I
walk out the door and I'm telling you
sometimes it's like what is a hot mess I
don't know what I'm doing I got lost
like from from the closet to the front
of the door I don't know what happens
and he stops me he's like Mom turn
around like okay and it's like put
something else on this is my son and he
seven my son is seven I was going out on
a girl's night I was was going out on a
girl's night he was like oh well that's
a that's a dress oh that's never a good
way to
start that's a dress I was like okay
observant I know starting with oh he
walked me back into my closet 7 years
old and was like you should wear this
one I was like okay I
did I changed he shamed me I was like oh
God did you think he made the right
choice for you he did he's you know what
we we keep thinking that he might be an
engineer architect or something his how
how he looks at things are patterns he's
like a little hair Styles I think my son
is I mean he wears my gold L pants I'm
like damn oh Remy would totally wear
that he's a little rockar I know my
little my but it's kind of awesome to
see too because you know boys growing up
whenever I was a kid they would have
gotten beat up where I'm from like for
wearing anything cool really like so
yeah and it's so and I think that's why
my son loves New York too everybody's
their own character here and everybody
fits in it's awesome I do think I
remember when I first I moved from
California so I grew up in LA and I
remember when I moved here I remember
walking down the street and some girl
walked by me with blue hair and like it
was just kind of kind of like she was
carrying a cup of coffee like no one
cared and I was like this is hot yeah
and it's m yeah everyone's so different
I love it and I heard this weird thing
about you it's so weird but I just love
quirky things about people I don't even
know how I feel about Dill but you hate
Dill Dill should not exist I just love
the ear so this is me with invented it
oh no uhuh that's so that's like a weird
thing though isn't that like it tastes
like soap I just yeah cilantro like when
people garnish it I'm like oh that's so
exciting scoop no but yeah I have a
personal against Dy and I'm not sure why
yeah I think I I was something happened
in your childhood I was hurt by it D we
all have trauma things to talk about
therapy who hurt you or on the show Dill
hurt me offended
[Music]
[Applause]
me thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home oh